انا انا نظرتي نظره للمصالحه هذه الاخيره
هي انه
الامر الاساسي بالنسبه للسعوديه هو بناء
البلد
والرؤيه رؤيه 2030
ما ممكن انه الامير محمد
الدوله السعوديه تبني وتغير الاقتصاد
البلد من دون ما يكون في امن امان
والصواريخ هذه اللي تطلق من ايران وتطلق
من من اليمن وتهبط على السعوديه يعني ما
ممكن الواحد يبني بلد صحيح وانت في حاله
حرب اما مع ايران او مع جماعه ايران في
اليمن او في غير او في العراق فمن المهم
انه يحصل امان ويحصل امن في البلد
فاللي شفته انه الامير محمد حاول يدخل
الصين على الخط في المفاوضات مع
الايرانيين لتقليص او
يعني حصر ايران من من القيام بهذه
العمليات يعني يعني
[موسيقى]
هل ممكن توقع تنازل تراجع مثلا من
الايرانيين في سوريا على سبيل المثال في
العراق
لا منشوف الان يعني نحن الان في تجربه في
فتره تجربه تجربه نشوف اذا الصين لها هذا
الاثر ولا لا